provocative and political but cancel
culture means Beyond whether it's even
vandalism or art graffiti is being
scrutinized over what it can and can't
say I think a lot of people are are
fearful about having an opinion in their
work that others might disagree with
Obama
is one of Shepherd fairies most iconic
pieces
arguably the biggest name on the scene
of
scenost and activist
much of his work incorporating imagery
of important figures of our time
I have always made a lot of um portraits
of
um not just white people representation
matters but there have been some people
that have said to me oh you know you're
a white person you shouldn't paint
anything other than white people and I
say you know there's a way to look at
that as
um as actually really narrow-minded and
and exclusionary and so if the art
brings up a conversation like that that
I think is is constructive about who
gets the spotlight who's allowed to talk
about what issue I'm fine to be part of
that but if the idea is that I need to
not say anything because I'm I'm a
straightway white male I'm not gonna
um I'm not going to listen to that
you'll find that's an Arctic Spirit not
only in fairy's work but evident
throughout this Exhibition at the Sochi
Gallery the most comprehensive graffiti
and street art show ever to open in the
UK as a movement sticking two fingers up
to the establishment all of this can be
a hard thing to reconcile with is
commercialization this is the sanitized
version seemingly at odds with what
street art really stands for
today's street art is a commercial
Juggernaut shared on social media
courted by fashion houses accessible
relatable at its best subversive just
look around if the world looks exactly
how you want it to look then then fine
make decorative stuff if it doesn't
maybe try to say something the art
world's provocators
proud Katie Spencer Sky News